je t'aime je t'aime quand même
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors j'ai une obsession c'est le
partage le jour où j'ai découvert que je
pouvais me libérer de la peur de
transmettre pour la transformer en
quelque chose de vertueux ça a changé ma
vie
pour moi le partage m'a permis
d'atteindre un niveau supérieur et de
devenir médaillé olympique je vais
maintenant vous partager la méthode qui
m'a permis de réaliser mon rêve de gosse
alors pour ça on va faire un petit saut
dans le passé on est en 1992 à cette
époque là j'ai 7 ans et je suis un
garçon plein d'énergie je pratique une
multitude d'activités physiques je fais
du judo de la natation de l'athlétisme
du football bref les sports classiques
mais il y a aucun de ces sports là qui
me donne vraiment envie de continuer une
année supplémentaire
et à cette époque de ma vie j'habite à
Mâcon donc plutôt loin de la mer comme
quoi on n'a pas besoin d'être un breton
pour pouvoir faire du bateau
et c'est à ce moment-là que mes parents
décident de m'inscrire à un stage de
voile au petit club de la ville et c'est
sur la Saône que je tire mes premiers
bords en optimiste excusez la photo elle
est d'époque
et alors pour moi c'est une révélation
j'adore l'idée d'être sur l'eau ce
sentiment de liberté d'être à la fois au
contact de mes camarades mais je pouvais
aussi m'éloigner donc c'était vraiment
génial et je commence à découvrir les
joies des activités nautiques
à 8 ans comme ça un petit club j'ai
l'opportunité de participer à ma
première compétition alors évidemment
j'ai terminé dernier mais j'ai découvert
le jeu fantastique de la régate qui
challenge à la fois nos sensations et
nos capacités à prendre des décisions
je progresse petit à petit et à 14 ans
je participe à ma première grande
compétition internationale au
championnats du monde d'optimiste en
Martinique je termine 21e sur 150 et je
gagne même la dernière course
je sais qu'en rentrant de ce championnat
là je serai trop grand pour pouvoir
continuer à en optimiste mais j'ai envie
de continuer mon parcours dans la voie
alors maintenant on est en 2000 à cette
époque là j'ai 15 ans je sais pas si
vous vous souvenez les Jeux Olympiques
c'était à Sydney et comme tous les fanas
de sport j'essayais de regarder les jeux
à la télé mais je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez il fallait se lever très très
tôt le matin alors ce que je faisais je
me levais à 4h du matin je mettais mon
réveil j'ai essayé de pas faire de bruit
je descendais des escaliers à pas de
loups pour pas réveiller ni mes sœurs ni
mes parents parce que vous imaginez bien
j'avais pas le droit de regarder la télé
et je descendais je coupais le son tout
de suite et je me souviens d'une journée
en particulier je sais pas si c'était un
signe du destin mais c'était de la voile
à la télé
c'était la finale entre deux légendes de
mon sport favori l'anglais Ben and SLI
et le Brésilien Robert shade c'était la
finale et on allait savoir entre les
deux qui allait remporter la médaille
d'or ce qui était intéressant en plus
c'est que c'était le remake de la finale
des Jeux d'Atlanta 96 ou le Brésilien
avait battu l'anglais sur cette dernière
course le dernier jour cette fois-ci à
l'issue d'une course absolument épique
c'est l'anglais qui s'impose
c'est à ce moment précis que naît mon
rêve olympique à partir de là je sais
que moi aussi je vais essayer de faire
tout ce que je peux pour à la fois aller
aux Jeux olympiques et gagner une
médaille
alors maintenant j'ai 18 ans je fais
1m85 et ça y est je peux enfin faire du
laser comme ces deux grands champions
alors au début c'est un petit peu
compliqué j'ai du mal à rentrer dans les
50 meilleurs mondiaux dans la catégorie
senior mais mais très très bons
résultats dans la catégorie Jeune me
permet d'intégrer l'équipe de France
espoir en gros je suis le partenaire
d'entraînement des grandes équipes de
France et j'apprends à leur côté
à 20 ans j'ai encore grandi
et je commence à être un petit peu trop
grand pour le laser donc tout
naturellement je m'intéresse à la
catégorie supérieure qui s'appelle le
film c'est un bateau absolument mythique
qui a vu passer les plus grands noms de
la voile qui ensuite gagné les plus
grands trophées comme la Volvo océan
race ou la Coupe de l'America pour ceux
qui connaissent un petit peu la voile
le problème c'est que la Fédération elle
soutient pas du tout l'idée
en fait elle veut que je reste au
service de l'équipe de France de laser
parce que je suis particulièrement
performant dans les conditions avec du
vent notamment à cause de mon grand
gabarit cependant je sais que si je
reste en Laser pour les Jeux de Pékin
2008 j'ai aucune chance de me qualifier
parce que ça va se dérouler sur un plan
d'eau il y a pas de vent à shintao on
savait qu'il y aurait pas de vent du
tout
donc contre la vie de l'entraîneur je
décide quand même de passer dans la
catégorie supérieure en fine et de me
débrouiller seul
alors au début c'est assez compliqué
parce que le bateau le film c'est un
bateau extrêmement technique avec de
très nombreux réglages et je suis
absolument seul à La Rochelle pour
essayer de comprendre comment ça
fonctionne
mais lors de ma première régate au
Baléares à Palma et ben je gagne la
première course notamment grâce à une
fantastique technique au vent arrière
ce coup d'éclat me permet de devenir le
partenaire d'entraînement du Hollandais
piéter Yann Cosma qui était alors numéro
2 mondial et qui se préparait pour les
Jeux de Pékin 2008 il avait besoin de
progresser au portant et moi j'avais
besoin de progresser dans tous les
domaines
et c'est à ce moment-là que j'ai
découvert la puissance du partage parce
qu'en fait à ses côtés j'ai énormément
appris et lui aussi il a progressé au
niveau du vent arrière
à cette époque là pour moi c'est
vraiment facile parce que je gagne bien
plus que je ne donne
donc à l'issue de des Jeux de Pékin 2008
je suis prêt à me lancer à 100% dans la
campagne de Londres 2012 donc cette
fois-ci je peux plus travailler tout
seul et j'ai besoin des aides fédérales
donc je retourne voir la fédération qui
accepte de soutenir mon projet à deux
conditions
la première condition je vais garder le
niveau de financement du groupe espoir
c'est à dire à peu près 50% du budget et
la deuxième condition celle-ci est
beaucoup plus dure je vais devoir
partager tout ce que j'ai appris tout
seul
pendant deux ans avec Thomas un coureur
de l'équipe de France de laser qui passe
en fines pour cette nouvelle Olympiades
qui va garder son statut d'équipe de
France donc il sera financé à 100%
sans jamais avoir navigué sur le bateau
et à qui je vais devoir tout tout
apprendre
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est
qu'en voit l'Olympique il n'y a qu'une
seule place par pays pour aller aux Jeux
Olympiques
donc la façon dont on présente les
choses il a jamais navigué sur le bateau
il est numéro un chut numéro 2 et le
choix est déjà fait donc là la pilule
elle est vraiment super difficile à
avaler
cependant j'ai pas le choix et c'est à
ce moment que je décide de que je vais
positiver la situation
je décide que je vais toutes les
informations que je vais partager à mon
partenaire adversaire je vais les
retourner en quelque chose de bénéfique
pour moi
et ça ça a changé ma vie de façon
profonde
alors au début je vous cache pas que
j'ai vraiment l'impression de perdre
énormément de terrain dans la
qualification pour les Jeux de Londres
2012 Thomas en plus c'est un excellent
coureur et avec toutes les petites
astuces qui que je lui donne en plus il
ne cesse de me rattraper dans de très
nombreux domaines
ce que j'avais pas mesuré à l'époque
c'est qu'à chaque fois que je devais lui
partager un réglage une technique une
manière de fonctionner sur le bateau je
devais à chaque fois être absolument sûr
de la maîtriser moi-même parfaitement et
ça me permettait déjà de voir les
petites choses que je pouvais améliorer
ensuite quand je voyais Thomas utiliser
et les différentes informations je
pouvais aussi voir comment lui les
utiliser et qu'est-ce qu'il faisait
différemment et je pouvais utiliser
toutes les choses un petit peu mieux
pour les ajouter à ma propre technique
donc c'était déjà deux fois bénéfique et
je protège je ne faisais que progresser
au bout de deux années de collaboration
notre progression elle est absolument
fulgurante au début on était à peu près
dans les 30 meilleurs mondiaux et au
bout de deux ans on est quasiment à
chaque fois dans le top 10 et on
commence très régulièrement à rentrer
dans le top 5
cependant on sait que si jamais on veut
réussir à gagner encore en performance
et avoir une chance de monter sur le
podium il faut qu'on progresse dans un
autre domaine notamment celui du
matériel et plus particulièrement nous
avons besoin de développer une voile qui
sera parfaitement adaptée aux conditions
très spécifiques du plan d'eau des Jeux
de Londres 2012 qui était à weimousse
dans le sud de l'Angleterre on savait
que c'était essentiellement du vent et
des vagues
pour cela on décide de travailler de la
même manière avec le Finlandais et le
Suédois qui seront aussi nos adversaires
pendant les Jeux Olympiques
alors au début la collaboration elle a
énormément de mal à se mettre en place
vous imaginez bien en plus c'est des
pays nordiques ils sont très méfiants et
donc on a du mal à partager les
informations pourtant le contrat il
était clair au début on devait
uniquement échanger sur les réglages et
le matériel dans le but de développer
cette voile
mais voyant que ça a du mal à prendre et
que ça a du mal à fonctionner je décide
d'aller encore plus loin et j'accepte de
leur partager des informations sur ma
technique au vent arrière parce qu'à
cette époque là j'étais vraiment l'un
des meilleurs dans cette dans ce secteur
du jeu et tout le monde essayait de
comprendre comment je faisais
en leur donnant un peu plus ça a permis
de créer une vraie relation de confiance
et c'est ce qui nous a permis de créer
un groupe extrêmement stable et solide
notamment dans les six derniers mois
avant les jeux où quand chaque
sélectionné par pays se retrouve un
petit peu tout seul nous on a réussi à
garder notre groupe extrêmement stable
jusqu'à la veille des Jeux Olympiques on
s'est entraîné ensemble
là maintenant on est en décembre 2011 je
termine cinquième du championnat du
monde à peur en Australie et je suis
officiellement sélectionné pour les Jeux
Olympiques de Londres 2012 ça c'était
déjà une première victoire
à l'issue de cette annonce
Thomas mon partenaire d'entraînement
accepte de rester à mes côtés pour
m'accompagner dans la préparation les 6
derniers mois avant les JO
ça c'est une décision qui m'a
profondément touché
parce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est
que Thomas il avait été remplaçant pour
les Jeux d'Athènes en 2004
il a été remplaçant pour les Jeux de
Pékin en 2008 et il était une nouvelle
fois remplaçant pour les Jeux de Londres
2012 il avait à chaque fois donné quatre
années de sa vie soit 12 ans au total
pour à chaque fois échouer aux portes
des Jeux Olympiques alors il aurait pu
jeter l'éponge
mais pas du tout il était tellement
investi dans ce projet on avait créé une
telle histoire ensemble qu'il avait
envie d'aller jusqu'au bout et il m'a
poussé comme jamais dans les six
derniers mois juste avant les Jeux
je vais maintenant vous partager le
moment qui restera gravé pour toujours
en moi ou Jeux Olympiques alors on est
le jour de la finale ça fait déjà 10
jours qu'on s'affronte sur le plan d'eau
on a fait 10 courses je suis quatrième
au général deux points derrière le
Hollandais piéteriane pozma celui dont
vous vous souvenez tout à l'heure
je suis égalité de points avec le Croate
qui est cinquième et je suis un point
seulement devant le sloven qui est 6e je
sais que je pourrais nier de champion
olympique ni vivre champion olympique
parce qu'ils ont un petit peu trop
d'avance
je sais que je dois faire une course
quasi parfaite pour avoir une chance de
monter sur le podium
et là on est sur laquelle de mise à
l'eau on est prêt à mettre les bateaux à
l'eau et à partir sur la zone de course
pour participer à cette à cette dernière
vegane
et juste à côté de moi
il y a bennetti
lui il est deuxième au classement
général il sait que si jamais il balle
danois il sera champion olympique pour
la quatrième fois chez lui en Angleterre
et ce qu'il fera rentrer à tout jamais
dans la légende de la voile
je sais pas si vous vous souvenez c'est
celui qui 12 années plus tôt
m'avait donné envie d'être là celui que
j'avais vu à la télé
et à ce moment-là vous imaginez bien il
doit avoir une pression absolument
colossale sur les épaules et je me dis
que je vais faire une petite blague pour
détendre l'atmosphère
alors je le regarde et je lui dis bon
ben tu sais c'est toi qui m'a donné
envie d'être là je t'ai vu à la télé il
y a 12 ans j'étais petit je m'étais levé
exprès pour toi et là malgré toute la
pression qui pouvait avoir sur les
épaules il m'a simplement regardé il m'a
dit tu sais si tu navigue comme tu
navigue d'habitude je suis sûr qu'on
sera ensemble sur le podium ce soir
et là ce qui m'a donné sans rien
attendre en retour bah ça m'a absolument
libéré j'ai senti comme une vague de
fraîcheur m'envahir on allant sur la
zone de courge j'avais vraiment la
sensation que rien ne pouvait m'arriver
ça a été une course absolument folle
j'ai mené de bout en bout les trois
tours de la finale olympique
et effectivement
je suis monté sur le podium
avec lui
[Applaudissements]
alors aujourd'hui j'ai compris que la
peur de donner était une croyance
limitante
et j'invite chaque personne dans la
salle à choisir un élément précieux à
leurs yeux
et à le partager pour découvrir la
puissance de cette enseignement
c'est pour ça que maintenant je vais
vous inviter à vous lever
à regarder votre voisin dans les yeux
à lui serrer la main et à lui partager
ce qui vous vient spontanément
merci à tous
[Applaudissements]